you're just like they're doing it
they're doing the things you want them
to do and they're acting too
I care about that I want to keep
watching just like get to the next
action scene I really thought that we
were gonna turn on the camera for this
movie that we were just gonna be like
it's fun go out of great action it's
really cool can't wait for the next one
I was so surprised by
just how much of an epic crime fan at
like I would call Ray to a epic crime
drama I would call this an epic crime
fantasy
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John we just saw
a movie that we were so back and forth
on whether or not we should go to the
theaters and watch it not because we
weren't interested don't get me wrong we
saw the first three of this franchise in
the theaters we just know that with the
channel whatever this video is going to
get in views it would do phenomenally
better if we just waited on video on
demand just did a reaction at home
but something was calling that we had to
go see this
we couldn't let it go we did watch this
in IMAX and from the opening shot I went
God you know I never forgot the size and
scale of IMAX I forgot how effective if
you get really great sound design yeah
and a beautifully shot movie yeah yeah
like yeah this is effective this is the
first John Wick movie I've seen in IMAX
and every time I'm gonna re-watch it
it's going to be an iMac so thank you
IMAX for inviting us we've seen other
movies in IMAX that we have not
recommended but I'm going to tell you
watch this movie in IMAX it's two hour
40 something minute movie I could say
with the utmost confidence within the
first 20 to 30 minutes of this film
immediately was like I am so glad I did
not wait to watch this on video on
demand and on top of that too by the
time it ended I was especially glad I
was so happy you feel rewarded for the
decision the views don't matter John we
should watch this in the theaters what
matters is life and bullets
yeah please go ahead leave a like like
on this video that would mean a lot just
another heads up John Coy and I we're
gonna be having a panel at one Recon
this coming Sunday March 26th 11 o'clock
A.M if you are in attendance would love
to have you come say hi let's talk about
John Wick chapter four I'm gonna try
something out here I'm gonna give my
little percentage rating at the top
why what's the missing five
well that's what engagement's for you
wait around and you find out what that
five percent's all about the last 30
seconds of this video so John what is
the plot oh my goodness well John Wick
he's still trying to clear his name and
his debt to the high table and they're
still coming after him but there's a new
player a Marquee in the game who is uh
looking to wipe John out once and for
all and then a whole codery of other
interesting characters uh inter lope
into the plot along the way now for the
longest time I have said to myself that
the first John Wick movie is still my
personal favorite is the most personal
is the most intimate it's and it's best
structured in my opinion and I really do
like love the franchise as a whole but
the first one has always remained my
favorite one personally I agree this one
though I don't know if it's my favorite
one I will say that out of the sequels
it is my favorite one of them all I feel
like I could really argue with anyone on
why this one is the best one yeah it's
the best one it is an easy slam dunk and
it's not just because of the action
that's the crazy part like yes okay look
I don't want to give away a a lot of
these action scenes but there's such a
variety here that is of course
impressive why I was so hooked within
the first 30 minutes was because weirdly
in that First Act you don't spend a
whole lot of time with John Wick in that
First Act instead as you see in the
trailers you got all these other
characters now when you see a trailer
for this movie you go he's probably
gonna have like 20 minutes of screen
time Donnie Anne's probably gonna have
like a cool scene or two they have a
whole new list of characters here and I
thought they were all great yeah they
were excellent characters Donnie Yen
nine times out of ten you take an
international Superstar like that guy
you put them in some American Cinema
action film they go to waste they do not
waste this guy they let him have the
kind of Donnie in action you would want
when you watch one of his films from his
country absolutely and he also provides
a sort of like Lucid style to go along
with his character who's blind but more
importantly than that it's a great
performance he's intimidating scary
funny but she becomes so emotionally
invested in him he had lines in this
movie that earned the biggest Applause
yeah absolutely and I mean you could
just tell he's so inhabited especially
the role of a blind character in a movie
like this even that didn't play as
typical I feel like usually they just
have super powers and can sense
everything but the way he threw himself
into really feeling and creating the
movement and the language of this
character on screen was something really
impressive to behold he really went all
out this movie to me it just had this
great seamless blend of anime Western uh
neo-noir video game any kind of action
you've ever seen in your life the
movie's really long before watching it I
was kind of under the presumption that
it would just be over indulgent I
thought it would just be a movie where
it's two hours and 40 minutes of
whatever action scene they could throw
at the screen and that's all it's really
going to be this movie allowed the
scenes when there was an action to truly
breathe to truly have a mood it's truly
hone in and evoke stuff coming from
within its themes about existentialism
literally the point of life what is the
purpose of this you know I have asked
myself this when watching the John Wick
film stuff
why are you still doing this why don't
you just give it up and die and then
themes about fatherhood themes about
friendship things that Brotherhood
things I was not expecting this movie to
do it's the most artistic one of them
all from behind the camera it really
brought it back to that really awesome
cinematography that I kind of missed
from the first one but they did
something that felt literally like I was
watching a graphic novel come to life in
so many ways yeah and it also really
inhabits and uses the palettes of
everywhere it goes in the world because
this is a very Globe trotting movie in
Japan you're in France you're in all
sorts of places and each one of them
really feels immersive and like they
really thought about every possible way
they could use the features of these
places to accentuate the action but also
to accentuate yeah the the visual
palette of the movie and there's a
certain Elegance I think coming out of
the theater we were talking about the
raid and The Raid 2 and the sort of jump
between those movies and I think this
has a lot of that strained Elegance not
that it's necessarily only about the
crime world because we've seen it
applied to there but it also just has
this desperation of Will and character
and it is like one of those movies that
you don't expect to come out of feeling
like it is a fully fleshed character
journey and yet it does it is because
it's an ensemble piece their stories are
equally important in this whole journey
that all centers around John Wick
because to me this movie's like if The
Raid 2 met the Fast and Furious Universe
in a way sure because of the physics of
the human body in here because yeah it
does get a little bit ridiculous of
course how many High Falls can he
withstand not just him
I love most all of these people in this
war yeah when you reach a certain level
of Hitman in this Society do you just
get overpowered or some kind of like
body armor beyond your suit but the
movie is still very intense I thought it
was just gonna be popcorn fun you know
how the the third John Wick movie starts
off with this great 20 minutes in New
York and I thought that was going to be
the movie but I noticed that no one was
even really applauding in the first 30
minutes we were just so engrossed by
what was going on with the story and the
action had a great intensity to it
throughout and that's what you want from
this movie this sense of like real
personal stakes and finding myself on
this journey going
are they actually gonna kill this guy
off or not yeah you know I mean you
think that about John you think that
about multiple people and I think this
one and the first one I think make
really nice bookends because you have
such a uh fruitful blend of yes action
and beautiful Cinema but also an
emotional core that really does feel
vital like the second and third movie
love them both as well but there is much
more that's just motivated by the lore
and the World building and just the
rules that apply to everybody who's a
Hitman that's all there because you had
the personal one with the first one and
then you got the Big World building and
the crazier hide in action in physics
with the human body and this kind of
encompasses what the previous three
films did and kind of even better at the
same time too I gotta say too a guy who
I kind of whenever I hear is playing a
bad guy I kind of roll my eyes at now
because I'm like of course he's playing
a bad guy oh he had it he was effective
he was great Bill Skarsgard he plays a
French man where several times during
this movie I would have one or two
thoughts this guy's the best villain out
of the whole franchise secondly I would
have many times where I go
I love the philosophical questions that
are here in this movie hiroyoki Sonata
he had this wise man almost Ronin Shogun
assassin-like quality to him and here
I've often joked about how they always
have to make him do sword fights in
movies in American Cinema I think this
is his best one sure no no no 100 I mean
I'm sure that this got to be I I would
imagine he would have even had input on
it like it is very satisfying and it
doesn't distract you that way and there
are also multiple other weapons at plays
I think the world really sweeps you up
into feeling like yeah this is this is
right for this scene rather than just oh
we got a mirror let's do that and also
shouts out to Arena sawyama who who
plays his daughter character because she
really threw down along with everybody
else to sell everything like during her
fight scenes as well and just her
presence on screen I thought she uh lent
a beautiful sort of warmth even though
that's not how I would describe like the
characters necessarily to the pursuit
readings because so much of this has to
do with the real toll and cost of living
this life being a part of this world and
the fact that there's always some loose
end that is going to come back and come
for karma essentially yeah their story
in this movie greatly affects the
trajectory of this entire Epic Journey
that you go on throughout this film
foreign
Scott Atkins he's the one guy who you
bring over here and you're mainly like I
just want to see him have cool fights he
has great fights and as a fan of action
Cinema to be able to watch a movie where
you got hirio kusanata you got Donnie
Yen you got Scott Atkins in here and
they really utilize them it's like an
action it's like a wet dream man how
come to the library just like they're
doing it they're doing the things you
want them to do and they're acting too
I care about that I want to keep
watching just like get to the next
action scene I really thought that we
were gonna turn on the camera for this
movie that we were just gonna be like
it's fun go out of great action it's
really cool can't wait for the next one
I was so surprised by
just how much of an epic crime fan at
like I would call Ray to a epic crime
drama I would call it epic crime fantasy
yeah 100 it still has that peripheral
fun there is a lot of latent humor
that's not overt absolutely wants you to
chuckle and have a good time with it
yeah it's just got so much flavor and
there's still more to the world of the
continental and the high table and all
that stuff and nothing it's like it
could easily become pretentious or
become silly and I think they find the
perfect blend to prevent that from
happening and yeah I mean you mentioned
that fast and furious kind of physics
but they never uh go silly with the way
they portray and capture anything it
always feels as grounded as possible
yeah and that so that sells the things
that feel a bit more out there they have
these great actions these have some
great wonders in there they do things
that are like I can't how do they keep
topping themselves how do they keep
finding inventive ways that keep
surprising me uh at every turn of man
this doesn't feel like you're just
pulling from your previous movies
the action in this movie has such an an
amazing blend of a wide variety of
styles from swordplay to of course the
gunfu as they call it yeah the the
nunchucks scene was with like they
really made a full-on John Wick nunchuck
fights which I've been waiting for in
American Cinema for so like no one hits
themselves in the nuts it's amazing and
like you got shirukin throwing stars
you've got dogs horses pretty much
anything you've seen in a previous John
Wick movie plus more new kinds of fun
yeah the car play my god there were
shots in here I was like I can't believe
they're doing this there's one that
starts off with this
above shot wonder is all I'll say yes
yeah if you're looking down for a long
time you'll know it's one more time it's
brilliant Ian McShane gives another
great performance once again shouts out
to Lance Reddick not in this film a lot
but when he's there it's very effective
I really appreciated him being here may
he rest in peace because yeah the second
he shows up on screen I'm like God damn
it is a bummer not to have this guy it
really is also I I cannot remember the
actor's name but another sister his
name's Lawrence Fishman are you Sam
Samuel Jackson no no Lawrence Fishburne
uh Lawrence Fishman Barry King Brown
Clancy Brown also great
um but no no the track guy who plays
tracker no but there's a character
nobody I mean that's how I suppose his
name's nobody or just a Tracker he's
great yeah yeah he's great uh he is one
of the best lines in the movie makes for
a really interesting wild card yes and
an interesting thematic compliment to
John the five percent that was kind of
missing for me there was maybe like 10
minutes in this movie where I was going
you can probably pick it up a little bit
but out of two hours and 40 minutes I'm
like to have only 10 minutes of that
film where I'm going I'm kind of waiting
for you to get back to a little bit more
of a rhythm here a little bit more pulse
I don't even know if it's 10 minutes it
might have been like five where I had
the thought go off in my head for a
second of speed up a little bit
regardless I don't even think when that
scene was happening I would want this
movie to not have that scene I would
still prefer that scene being in there
secondly
um yeah just a couple of questions that
I would occasionally have with this
movie of
how's he flying to all these places I
did have that exact thought I was like
who's this airplane guy that seems like
a real easy way to get yourself caught
it turned into that I'd say it's a
couple little nitpicks how's it going
from A to Z exactly because he's kind of
globetrotting you know John Wick's got a
special tunnel that goes under the
Atlantic Ocean that's all yeah you know
screw him bumping it up 97 oh you're
almost at my rating yeah you're almost
in my rating what are you I'm a 98.5 G
nice nice what's that excuse me
I have no idea I'm just leaving it up
there because I'm sure there's I got my
10 minutes we'll probably go away on my
re-watch that 1.5 is for anybody who
comes up to me with a point that I would
go oh okay fair yeah it's for the
airplane thing that's what it's for but
guys I love the hell out of this movie
terrific
um I can't wait to watch this two to
three more times watch it in IMAX
because it's well worth it it's amazing
all right guys thank you so much for
being here and uh subscribe leave a like
I just want to come we'll talk to you
guys soon
thank you
foreign